a recent article in The New Yorker I  don't know if you saw this it revealed  that 1 in 10 Europeans are conceived in  an Ikea bed that's a real I didn't make  that up that is a real story one in 10  Europeans conceived in an Ikea bed now  the story has been getting a lot of  attention and IKEA just released this  video in response take a look  great news the rumor is true yes one in  10 Europeans is conceived in an Ikea bed  with your baby be one of the lucky ones  how to know what to do thanks for asking  we'll show you there are a few subtle  indicators  [Music]  and assembly couldn't be easier just  follow the simple step-by-step  instructions yep  making a baby oh yes you're gonna make a  great dad  [Music]  exactly oh yes whoo yeah that's great Oh  coming along oh look at that  [Music]  [Music]  yeah congratulations  IKEA bed baby  perfect  [Applause]  [Music]  you